démarrage du nettoyage
[Musique]
où
nous voilà en république dominicaine
mois de janvier mois de février y en a
marre de la neige
on part au soleil aujourd'hui je vous
parle d'un robot aspirateur robot
aspirateur xiaomi robot rock en fait un
robot rock société dans lequel shlomi
l'entrée dans le capital et robot rock a
sorti le premier aspirateur deux chiens
au mit qui fonctionne super bien et là
ils sortent leur propre aspirateur
souvent propre marque et c'est celui
dont je vais vous parler aujourd'hui
il s'agit du robot rock s5 est ce que je
vous propose c'est en retourne au studio
comme ça je vous le présenter plus en
détail
aujourd'hui on parle de ça ce carton ça
là je sais pas si ça vous parle c'est le
robot troc
c'est un aspirateur intelligent c'est un
objet connecté
je suis très content parce que c'est un
bon temps je me dis et si j'avais un
aspirateur intelligent parce que
franchement passer l'aspirateur
s'appelle toute la maison c'est sympa ça
va deux minutes mais quand une bête
quand on est obligé comme ça peut le
faire à votre place vous dites oui oui
tiens grands voiliers vous êtes très
content alors je vous demande comment ça
marche parce qu'au final cet objet
intelligent n'est pas juste un
aspirateur
bien évidemment il un petit laser qui
vous permet de savoir exactement quels
sont les objets de les contourner
il s'adapte complètement sur les
différents types de sol sur lequel il va
être du bois du lino de la moquette et
compagnie ça c'est franchement cool et
en plus de ça il va laver donkey
l'aspirine et wife est tout à votre
place
et vous ça vous laisse du temps pour
faire ce que vous voulez c'est cool
sumud 4dans regardez moi ce truc super
classe la petite balayette qui va bien
qu'ils tournent qui nettoie tous ça qui
aspirent les petites roulettes
ça c'est la partie laser qui va vraiment
savoir la direction à l'intérieur on a
le petit bac un filtre de rechange et du
câblage
la première chose ça vous le posez au
sol ça vient se clipser l'a ensuite on a
le câble secteur juste là ça c'est pour
la partie électrique
ensuite le roman lui-même au louvre
prône l' on tire on a le bac on a le
filtre donc c'est cool parce qu' aussi
un filtre de rechange après vous
l'ouvrez comme ça vous enlevez vous
cochonneries vous les mettez à la
poubelle et on en parle plus donc ça
c'est hyper cool et là vous avez petit
balayette pour venir nettoyer votre
filtre sur le si vous avez des petits
boutons allumer éteindre le renvoyer à
la base pour aller se recharger
ça c'est pour lui firent d'aspirer dans
une zone limitée là par exemple lit dans
la cuisine je veux définir par exemple
qu'il nettoie q la cuisine je peux
définir la zone dans laquelle je qui
viennent nettoyer par exemple permettent
là je peux l'agrandir l'arrêterait
sillage savez comme je veux la voyez par
exemple nettoyer uniquement la zone que
je les définit pas au delà ça
franchement c'est hyper cool par exemple
je peux créer aussi si je souhaite un
mur virtuel
je lui dis tout ça là tu ne vas pas dans
cette zone est une nettoie que la partie
la voyez là typiquement il en train de
suivre mur virtuel et il va aller faire
toute la zone de la cuisine
sauf là où effectivement il ya le bureau
virtuel je peux par exemple plus donner
une zone interdite une zone dans
laquelle je ne veux pas qu'ils aillent
par exemple ça peut être la chambre de
mon fils parce qu'elle est trop en bazar
il veut pas qu'il y aille ou par exemple
toute cette partie là hop je prends je
fais glisser toute cette zone interdite
l'a ensuite la recadrer je peux la faire
pivoter je fais exactement ce que je
veux il va nettoyer toute cette partie
là mais tout le reste il ira pas c'est
strictement impossible
bien évidemment pour faire tourner tout
ça il vous faut une application me aune
de xiaomi sur lequel vous allez pouvoir
rajouter votre robot parce que oui ce
robot from troc fait partie de
l'écosystème chili et ça c'est
franchement hyper cool parce que du coup
une fois que vous avez votre application
avec tous vos objets connectés chez omis
vous allez pouvoir le rajouter vous
allez avoir des stades vous allez savoir
exactement dans quelle zone il est passé
qu'est ce qui l'a inspiré qu'est-ce qui
a loupé savoureux dessine votre
intérieur et c'est franchement génial
[Musique]
alors par exemple hop je pense est
partie la gelée blanche ça je branche
voilà la vie imposé mon robot il
s'allume
ils chargent ensuite dans les paramètres
de mon application je vais rechercher
appareil à proximité ça me fait un petit
scan ça me trouve robot troc appareils a
ajouté
donc là dans mon application j'ai mon
robot qu'elles ont pour l'instant riscal
pas donc il n'a pas le dessiner la carte
mais vous allez voir des violences le
scan ça va complètement tout me faire
j'ai le niveau de batterie
j'ai la zone qui a été nettoyée j'ai le
temps que tu été nettoyé et ensuite je
peux choisir nettoyage cible est défini
une zone recharger nettoyage est partout
nettoyer du nettoyage deux hommes ce qui
est bien avec l'aspirateur c'est que
vous avez un historique de nettoyage
vous voyez exactement tout ce qui venait
nettoyer le temps qu'il a mis pour tout
nettoyer
[Musique]
après c'est très pratique avec ce robot
sait qu'il va vraiment venir longer les
murs il fait de façon très méthodique il
fait dire par l'autre côté ils voient un
obstacle il contours il fait tout le
tour
hier paris revient la jeune lancé un
tout nouveau scan et la voyez sur
l'application en même temps qu'il avance
on voit la pièce qui se dessine on voit
la pièce qui apparaît en fonction de ce
qu'ils repèrent et plus il va avancer
plus va peaufiner votre intérieur et il
va connaître réellement votre intérieur
les objets qui contourne la par exemple
au milieu c'est moi qui l'a contournée
et voyez il en train de me décider
là où la cuisine là le salon elle très
blanc que vous voyez c'est son chemin et
vous allez voir exactement là où il a
aspiré et même qu'il ait une forme
auront s'impose absolument aucun
problème parce que vraiment venir loger
tout nettoyer aspirer c'est vraiment
hyper apprécié parce que vous optimisez
complètement alors l'aspiration et
franchement bien mais on va pas dans un
niveau de détail comme si vous preniez
vos inspirateur et que vous avez cherché
dans tous les moindres recoins et tous
les moindres détails
il va vous dégrossir votre intérieur à
je dirais 80 85 % il vous restera faire
un petit nettoyage mais franchement
c'est pas bien grave
en plus de ça il passe sous les meubles
il passe bien évidemment sous les lits
il vous enlève les moutons si tenté
qu'il y en ait un problème le paramétrer
quand il passe sur un tapis pour qu'il y
ait une aspiration qui soit complètement
adapté à votre tapis c'est franchement
hyper cool
[Musique]
par exemple dans l'application vous avez
vachement paramètres pouvez enregistrer
la carte de votre appartement ça c'est
franchement bien comme ça vous pourrez
définir des zones où il va pouvoir
ensuite à les inspirer mode accélération
tapis ça je vous le recommande
franchement parce qu'il a identifié le
tapis et il a complètement optimiser la
puissance pour venir les nettoyer et une
foi qui sortira du tapis il va reprendre
sa respiration normale ça c'est
franchement hyper cool aussi
et par exemple vous allez venir
programmer votre nettoyage et vous
pouvez définir par exemple que tous les
jours à la même heure il va venir
nettoyer vous le répéter de façon
quotidienne hebdomadaire les week-ends
vous pouvez lire personnalisés vous
définissez l'heure à laquelle vous
voulez que ça commence et le mode de
nettoyage standard silencieux fort max
[Musique]
donc ce qui est vraiment super là dedans
c'est que lorsque vous partez au boulot
par exemple l'aspirateur se lance il
fait le boulot vous rentrez c'est propre
c'est nettoyez vous n'avez strictement
rien vu et ça faut reconnaître quand
même que c'est un sacré confort
[Musique]
autre avantage et non des moindres c'est
qu'il va franchir les obstacles jusqu'à
2 cm je pense notamment aux pas de porte
il passe de fut sans aucun problème vous
avez entre qui traînent ils passent de
fûts et de toute façon si vous avez un
objet et qui pose problème avec le laser
et repère les objets ils les contourner
même lorsqu'il va arriver vers des
escaliers ebook sont des escaliers il va
pas sauter dans le vide il fenomeno
et elle continue son boulot chez moi y'a
pas d'escalier donc difficile de vous
faire la démonstration comme quoi
effectivement il ne tombe pas des
escaliers du coup je voulais me sur la
table basse il va complètement
contourner le vide il fait le tour de la
table basse et ça vous pouvez utiliser
de la même manière chez vous il va pas
du tout tomber s'ils rencontrent des
escaliers au contraire il va faire le
tour donc ça franchement c'est hyper
sécurisé c'est franchement hyper cool
j'aime bien parce que ça apporte
vraiment nouveau confort à la maison je
dis ça ça vous évite tout le temps avec
votre aspirateur à venir vous embêter et
hop voilà mais par là ça vous évite
d'avoir à tout en vous embêter et à
devoir passer l'aspirateur c'est une
corvée je déteste faire le ménage je
pense qu'a priori tout le monde je sais
pas si c'est votre cas mais des tests
aménage d'ailleurs si vous aimez de
faire ménage marqué le mois aux
commentaires que je comprenne pourquoi
parce que je déteste faire le ménage
c'est vraiment un truc qui m'insupporte
néanmoins je déteste vivent dans de la
poussière la crasse c'est vraiment pas
mon truc
donc on est bien obligé de s'y coller et
le fait d'avoir un aspirateur comme ça
qui est complètement automatisée
programmable qui scanne votre maison qui
passe partout qui va adapter la solution
en fonction du sol c'est le fait d'avoir
un vrai reporting et d'avoir des vrais à
leers toutefois il ya un problème
vous êtes au courant en temps et en
heure de ce qui ce fait vous savez où il
est passé et vous faire un compte rendu
et ça c'est franchement juste
extraordinaire
[Musique]
alors bien évidemment tout ça ça un coup
d'aspirateur n'est pas forcément cadeaux
il coûte un peu moins de 400 euros mais
pour services rendus
franchement c'est génial et pour voir le
nombre de techno vous avez à l'intérieur
tous les capteurs qui sont embarqués à
l'intérieur dans les capteurs vous les
avez là vous les avez là vous les avez
là c'est juste top il marche vachement
bien je peux que vous le recommander et
je dise à la main sur le coeur voyez le
coeur est là j'adore vraiment en tout
cas moi je peux passer beaucoup plus de
temps à bosser et beaucoup moins inspiré
ça croyez moi rien que pour ça c'est un
grand bonheur dites moi ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que des robots aspirateurs
ce quelque chose qui pourrait vous
intéresser
est-ce que vous avez déjà un robot
aspirateur peut-être même de la
concurrence sur naples 1 est-ce que ce
robot là le robot troc s 50 52 peut vous
intéresser s'il vous intéresse bien
évidemment que j'ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description je vous invite à
marquer ce que vous en pensez pour vous
les tâches ménagères c'est vraiment une
corvée ou alors vous aimez bien il ya
des gens qui aiment les savoirs dites
moi donc ce que vous pensez de cette
jolie bête est ce qu'elle peut vous
tentez will go on s'y croit comment et
quelle est la fonction qui pourrait être
plus vous intéresser la programmation le
reporting de détection d'objets en tout
genre de choses vous invite à marquer
tout ça en barque voilà soyez sages
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo je
vous embrasse et à très bientôt
ciao
non